- All right, Tracy.
Tracy, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in Littleton Colorado.
- And tell me about your childhood yet.
Both of your parents as a kid?
- Yes. Yes, until I was about
16, 17 years old, and we
my dad took good care of us.
We never once lived in an
apartment or anything like that.
We always had a four, five bedroom house,
front yard backyard.
my dad was an auto body
and fender man, an automotive division.
Automotive cars and stuff.
And we always went water skiing
on the weekends, in the summertime.
And, we did a lot of snow,
sports in the winter time.
And we had, we had a lot
of fun then,
my parents, they.
in the automotive division,
in the automotive business,
my dad's friends, they were all bikers.
You know what I mean, brothers fast.
So we lived in nice houses
and stuff like that.
It wasn't, all tore up,
nasty like or anything's
real nice houses and stuff.
But my dad, he smoked pot,
My mom smoked pot.
And so at a young age,
that was always around me.
And at a young age,
I started smoking pot
and drinking alcohol,
And by the time I was 16, 17 years old
I was a real bad alcoholic.
You might say a minor alcoholic,
and I couldn't handle my alcohol.
I'd always come home on the weekends
with a black guy or something,
from kegger parties and stuff like that.
I was just totally out of control.
I used to tear my dad's house up,
after my parents got divorced,
and he just got tired
of my shit and he said
pack your shit and get out of here.
And I packed my and I left, and I went
down to San Diego and was
down there for a little while
at his best friend's
house from high school.
That only lasted a couple
of weeks and I left there.
So I started my journey up
the state of California.
And, I was in Carlsbad, California
Oceanside for about four months, just
hanging out on the beach,
just being a beach bum.
And then I got tired of that.
And I ended up in Las
Vegas for a little while.
And from there I entered Hollywood,
and I didn't really know
much about Los Angeles,
I really didn't know
anything about Los Angeles
and there I was standing
on sunset Boulevard
looking down the Boulevard
and it just went forever,
It just never ended.
and I was scared, I was really scared.
And I met this prostitute,
and we went to her little hotel room
and we spent a little time together,
and I left.
And I was just hanging out on the streets,
panhandling, so on and so forth.
And I ran into her again,
we went to her house again
her little hotel room and we kicked it
for a little while, and she
offered me a place to stay.
She could see that I
was scared, I was young.
I was only like about 18, 19 years old.
And so she kind of taught me
everything about the streets,
how to hustle people,
how to deal with them
and how to work mother...
excuse my language,
how to work a person out of
their money and so on, so forth.
And so one night, she took off
and to go pull some dates
and she never came back.
So I figured, well, she's in jail,
she's gonna write me and this and that.
And you know, I kept the rent
and paid by selling weed to
the whores on the hostel
of her, her girlfriends.
And I never got a letter
from her or anything,
So I figured, well, maybe she's dead.
And so I just continued on with my life.
And I got caught selling two joints
to a female who was a police officer,
and I didn't sell her no two joints,
I gave her two joints.
And she handed me five dollars
and she said, that's for you,
And your friend can get some beer.
And I said, no, I find we
got, we got our own money,
That's just for you for free.
And she took off and then
the whole parking lot
sealed up with police cars.
And so off, I went to LA County jail.
And then from there, I went
to Corcoran state prison.
When they first opened
up with three years,
they gave me the max, three
years for selling two joints.
And now it's illegal
that three years ended
up being 33 years of
incarceration back and forth,
new turns,
to new numbers.
And they basically stole
my whole life away from me,
just for two joints.
Now I'm off of on parole,
I have my own place.
I was so beat up by the system by CDC,
just in and out of San Quentin,
I've been to Pelican Bay
new Folsom, Corcoran,
all Calipatria.
I've been to all these prison yards
to tell you the truth man
when people say that I'm a convict,
so what that don't
really mean nothing, man.
It just means that you've been locked away
from society for many
years on the cookie sheet.
you had nothing coming.
And a lot of people that are in prison,
they have something coming.
It's just, they're just being so,
used and abused by CDC,
just taking their life away
for these petty ass crimes.
That really ain't about shit.
But that's how society is.
So I went to recovery
and I was in Walden house
in 2000 and I wanted to
be in an iron worker.
And that's what I began
is being an iron worker.
And I worked iron for about two years,
and I relapsed and I told my
boss, you know, I gotta go.
It's not safe for me being
around all this heavy machinery.
And he goes, man just go back to work.
And I go, I relapsed.
And he goes, I know I don't
give f...k a about that.
Just go back to work.
And I said, no, I'm going
to go back to my addiction.
And I picked up my check and
back to my addiction I went,
that was the biggest mistake
I ever made in my life.
So I carried on in my addiction going back
and forth on violations,
so on and so forth.
I finally got off of parole.
I did all of it,
and then caught another number
and get all of that one.
Now I'm free I don't
owe them people nothing,
they don't owe me nothing,
I'll never get nothing
from them, for all the
years that they stole
from me because my own stupidity
of not showing up on my
parole dates and stuff.
But I'm, I'm better now.
I got, little things working for me.
They're not too terrific,
but you gotta crawl
before you walk.
I just had a bad addiction
to methamphetamine,
slamming methamphetamine and
my girlfriend got killed.
Somebody killed her and dumped
her body side of the freeway,
And that was enough for me,
I just said, I'm gonna stop.
And I stopped using that.
Then I used heroin to get
away from the crystal.
Now I used fentanyl to
get away from the heroin.
Now I'm trying to kick the fentanyl.
Which ain't easy,
but each day and time easy does it.
and so my life has been,
just back and forth,
back and forth in and out
these cages and this and that.
Not too much life left,
I'm what?
57 years old now,
everybody says, well
you look like you're 37.
That's because when you're locked up
it preserves you.
But I don't feel it on the inside.
So now I got me a little
job over here at this hotel.
I clean up the restrooms
and the common areas.
I lived there for free and I do my thing,
and all my friends there and pretty much,
that's it for the days,
but I can say that,
these kids that come to these streets.
I wish they really knew
what was ahead of them,
before they get caught up in CDC.
Which I don't think CDC is as bad
as it was.
Now back in the day because,
Arnold Schwarzenegger kind of
changed everything and kicked
out a whole lot of lifers
and this and that, which is
good thing, but these streets will take
and chew you up in a second.
Couple years you won't
have no teeth and so on
and so forth and you'll be
looking like you're 85 years old
and you're only 25.
People get so intense into
their hustle from the streets.
They don't realize that they're hustling,
a person when they're not
really trying to, but they are.
it just,
it sets off a lot of feelings with people,
and how they've been
caught up in this and that
what they went through,
where they've had to,
tweak trick with their own race.
With their own race, with
their own gender and stuff
like that to make money
and so on and so forth
just to survive when they
really didn't have to do that
because it wasn't going
to die in the first place.
They just wanted the money
for, they could go get high.
Other than that am cool.
- What was the lowest point of your life?
- The lowest point of my life?
I don't know.
The lowest point in my
life is where I was having
the most fun, with my addiction.
I found out a long time ago,
that it's not that hard
to feeding an addiction.
Matter of fact, it can
make it work for you.
I mean, you can sell crystal and all that.
There's really no money in it anymore.
It's just, it's just pay
for your high and cumulate
few females around you.
But the lowest has been,
I don't know what the lowest is.
I know I've been really
bad in my addiction
to where every time I get a
shot, man, I was just like, man
it makes me feel like shit.
I wanted to get off this stuff so bad.
Thank God I had the strength to get
off of it,
and the heroin.
- And what was the best part of your life?
- The best part of my life,
that's to become right now.
I just got put on social security
and I'm getting a nice little fat retro
and I'm going to go buy me
a nice four wheel drive,
pickup and buy me a brand
new YZ 250, and I'm gonna
to these tracks and do what
I've always wanted to do
since I was a kid.
That is
Just just right there, on the MX track.
- Good for you.
what do you think about your childhood,
may have led you down this path?
- Well, my childhood was a good childhood.
My dad gave me everything I wanted,
if I wanted a motorcycle,
he got me a motorcycle
and might not been the kind that I wanted
but he got me one.
Dad can I have a pool table?
He got me a pool table.
The only thing that I didn't get was
a swimming pool in the backyard.
(laughs)
You know what I mean?
But we always had jet boats,
water skiing and stuff like that.
I had a good, good childhood.
I went to Kent College junior High School
and Columbine High School.
Yeah, the one that was on TV
for the shootings and stuff.
it was predominantly white,
we didn't have really too many
other races at that school.
There was a lot of tension there
between the jocks and the stoners.
that's what created that thing in
Columbine i think.
Because I know I went through a lot
of peer pressure when I was
going through high school
and stuff,
but yeah I had a good, good childhood.
- What would you say?
Can you put a finger
on anything about your,
your youth that may have led
you to where you are now?
- Yeah when I was five, I
had a sister that was three
had his sister.
we was being baby sitted
on my parents anniversary.
my sister got ran over
by a car and she died
in front of me and I always
thought it was my fault.
I told her, watch out for the cars
and I should've been more aware
of what I was saying to
her than her being aware
of what I was saying to her and
our babysitter was busy
smoking my mother's cigarettes
and stuff, than watching us.
And my sister got hit
by a car and she died.
That was, I've always taken
that upon my shoulders,
that it was my fault.
I just recently talked to
my brother after 30 years,
after I've left home because
I was a burden to the family.
I just was a bad alcoholic, always drunk.
just out of control, and
my little brother told me,
first thing, he said
he says, Hey Tracy, it wasn't your fault.
I said my fault about
what? he was about wendy.
And he never even knew Wendy.
He wasn't even alive when,
when wendy was alive,
so he never got to know her.
It kinda really touched my
heart that he said that.
I talked to my brother
about every other day now,
He's doing good.
He's raised two daughters
since I left home.
Fully grown girls.
He's doing his thing, he's doing good,
he's a truck driver for McDonald's.
He delivers, they're
producing all that stuff,
and meat and all that stuff,
around Colorado,
like out in Wyoming,
Nebraska and stuff like that.
He makes a hundred thousand a year.
He's doing good.
He doesn't even look like
my little brother anymore.
Matter of fact, he looks older than I do.
like I said, prison preserves you.
- How old were you and your sister?
- I was five, She was three.
She got hit, she would have been.
She would have been a hell of a hell
of a woman if she would have made it.
She would've never been
hit my mom told me that,
God had a special place
for her that he needed her,
And I never could understand that.
Why does he need her
if he has so many dead people on his list?
So that was a major loss to
our whole family because,
how things pivot around females and
our whole family was
just pivoted around her
because she was so funny all the time and,
always in a good mood.
She used to come and get me food
in the back window when
my mom would send me
to bed without no dinner.
cause I've been bad
and so on and so forth.
And here she come with a
whole arm full of food for me
she was, she was my sister.
- Do you feel like maybe
that kind of set the set the,
your path in a different direction?
- Yeah that's what, I just deep inside
we don't really realize
that these things we hold
on to, and it makes a big
difference in our lives.
That's what I've been taught
going through Walden house and stuff.
I held onto it.
I still hold on to it,
I just never really knew
how to deal with it.
It's just,
deep inside.
it hurts .
To know that,
she was there at one
time and now she's gone.
I've always wondered what
her life would have been.
Like if she would have made it,
she would still be alive.
Then my brother came into the picture
I kind of had resentments towards him,
taking her place because
I wanted my sister back
and I couldn't have her back.
He knows, he knows that.
But he also knows that
I love him very much.
- Do you have hope now for
your, your future from here?
- Well, I don't know how much future I got
since am 57 years old now,
I've been feeling locked
up in LA County jail
since I've been 19 years old
back and forth, back and
forth, back and forth to where.
When they would go to
release me, I'm just like
why are you guys releasing me?
You're just going to bring me right back.
Because I had that number.
They basically want my ass out real good.
I don't do nothing.
I don't break into cars
and I don't sell dope.
I don't do nothing.
I just work my little job and
little hustle on the side.
Now I got a little bit of
money to work with from SSI,
So I'm going to go,
do my thing and just ride dirt bikes.
- Do you feel like living here
in the tenderloin is a dangerous place
for you to be hanging out?
- No, it's not.
It's not dangerous.
One person can only make it dangerous
to their selves, if they
don't watch their selves,
if they just let their selves go and just
don't give a F... about nothing
and just let themselves go
and be used and abused by other people.
Because other people out there
will use you and abuse you,
other people in their
addictions and stuff.
I feel that.
What was the question again?
- No, just, I just wonder
if being in this
neighborhood tenderloin where
there's drugs everywhere, makes it harder
for you to deal with your addiction?
- No, not really.
It's just kinda like,
I was thinking, well.
now I don't have a prison number.
What if I just get my motorcycle
and leave in my truck,
and leave.
Then what am I going to do
then I'm out of this County.
And if I get busted for something,
they sure in hell are gonna,
rack me up some years
because of my record,
but with five turns and stuff,
so probably better off staying here,
I don't really feel that the
tenderloins have threat me
because I know everybody
and everybody knows me.
There's some people
out there who just flat
out don't like me, but that's
their own personal feelings,
I haven't done nothing to
them, and they just keep it
to themselves.
But survival in the
Tenderloin is very easy
compared to Hollywood.
Hollywood is where all these young kids go
and they think they're
going to go to Hollywood
and be a movie star or
a rock and roll star.
And they're going to show their parents,
and they're not going to
buy their parents anything
and they're going to be rich.
They find out that
Hollywood is just nothing
but a ghetto and full of drugs
and pimps and whores, gangsters and
drag Queens and shit like that,
the street of broken dreams.
Hollywood has gotten nobody anywhere.
There's a few that made it.
A lot of these rock and roll,
stars like Astroworld and stuff
like that were on the streets, in LA.
Through a lot of their songs
and their lyrics come from.
it's like, living under the bridge and,
dancing with Mr. Brownstone,
we all know what that is.
- All right, Tracy.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah, no problem.
And good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Thank you.
- I've been wanting to do something
like this for a long time.
- Oh! Good.
I think it's therapeutic now
- Yeah, It's very therapeutic.
- Do you ever get a chance to
talk about this with anybody?
- Yeah, I talked to my caseworker
my counselor all the
time about this stuff.
I've talked to her so
many times and it's just,
I don't know what to say anymore
because I've covered everything with her.
I think that's why they put me
on SSI because I have so much,
background of being neglected used
and abused and, as a child.
My mom used to beat me
pretty bad when I was
before Wendy was born.
And when Wendy was born,
she, she quit beating on me.
So there was, no witness.
So she couldn't do that.
She didn't beat me really bad, but she,
she beat me and locked
me in a room for days
while my dad was out on the
road, truck driving and stuff.
- All right.
- Thank you so much.